boa noite
eu gostaria que você imaginar uma pessoa
fazendo pesquisa no laboratório imagina
um cientista como é que vocês imaginam
essa sua parte e pense um pouquinho
bom se vocês imaginaram um homem com
barba branca um senhor de idade
vocês não erraram porque é o que a
maioria das pessoas pensam então se
vocês olharem essa é uma convenção muito
famosa é a conversão de solveira e essa
foto muito antiga de 1926 a gente pode
ver a presença de uma única mulher aline
ó
amarre corria e os restantes homens como
vocês imaginaram todos os senhores de
barba fazendo a ciência
todos os homens e isso não mudou se a
gente olhar na convenção a mesmo tipo de
convenção que a convenção de 2011
nós vamos notar a presença de duas
mulheres uma em cada extremidade uma bem
longe da outra e pegando a mais nova
mais recente dessa convenção
nós temos apenas cinco mulheres e elas
também continuam longe uma das outras
distribuídas e a cara do cientista cara
do homem que faz ciência é essa mesma
cara e a gente não consegue ver nenhuma
mulher negra presente nesse grupo de
cientistas e essa é uma convenção muito
famosa porque todos os cientistas que
participam dela são pessoas que foram
convidadas
então eu nem você não faz a inscrição
você não paga a ser convidado
então olha a cara da nossa ciência
poucas mulheres muito longe uma das
outras e nem uma mulher negra e isso não
é uma coisa que acontece
só lá fora é uma coisa que acontece aqui
no brasil também existem os dados do
cnpq que ele trata
todas as bolsas desde a bolsa de
iniciação científica até as bolsas
senhores que seria a bolsa produtividade
ea gente pode ver isso acontecendo esse
primeiro recorde aqui que eu mostro para
vocês
ele traz o percentual de mulheres
brancas que fazem ciência no brasil
então começa com um número bastante
considerável que é 50% que bacana esse
agente foi olhando a maneira que ela
aumenta que segue na carreira esse
número aumenta 15% a gente sai de 50 e
agente vai pra 75 então esse é um número
muito pequeno a gente prestar atenção
então quer dizer que não aumenta tanto
assim
e se a gente pegar o recorte para
mulheres negras a gente começa com 30% e
esse número passa para 7% conforme você
aumenta com isso conforme você prossegue
na sua carreira
é um número muito pequeno então eu parei
e fiz um paralelo com a minha vida com a
minha carreira eu sou uma mulher negra
cientista
quantas mulheres negras cientista gente
vê no brasil hoje e isso eu percebi
quando eu fui da primeira palestra às
crianças
eu perguntei de um público infantil eu
tenho cara de cientista as crianças
falaram não
então porque é que nós não temos
mulheres negras na ciência por falta de
modelo por essa questão de ser o tipo as
crianças as meninas não se vêm
representadas
elas não se identificam nesse quadro
então elas vão querer cientista então
que eu parei e pensei eu como mulher
negra como é que eu consegui ser
cientista passar por todas essas
adversidades e chega a realizar meu
trabalho então parei pensei eu preciso
fazer alguma coisa para mudar essa
situação
então lembrei de toda a minha carreira
das dificuldades que eu passei para
cursar a universidade
eu morava em são paulo
no subúrbio de são paulo região muito
longe da universidade de são paulo eu
tive muita dificuldade para poder ir até
a universidade tinha que pegar atraente
e pegar o ônibus
então eu começa a contar sua história
com as crianças elas se identificam com
a minha carreira com a minha dificuldade
e mesmo assim o persistir eu cursei a
universidade num curso onde a maioria
era homens brancos onde não tinha
professoras mulheres negras que me
representar
então o modelo que eu tive para seguir a
minha carreira foi meu pai meu pai o
torneiro ferramenteiro um cara muito
inventivos que gosta de pesquisar que
gosta de estudar e ele me incentivou
então eu tive uma infância que foi
incentivada pela presença do meu pai e
isso me fez continuar e por que tão
poucas mulheres uma já que essas
mulheres estão o que as mulheres estão
fazendo
então eu fui em busca de respostas mas
as resposta pra isso
elas partiram de mim mesmo a história de
vida dessas mulheres é muito parecida
com a minha é uma história de luta e de
superação de enfrenta
então eu tive que correr atrás disso e
essas mulheres passaram por muito por
muito do que eu passei
é interessante falar sobre isso porque
isso influencia no trabalho que eu faço
hoje com as crianças e isso influencia
no trabalho que eu faço com as nossas
meninas pra que elas venham para a
ciência
eu gosto de mostrar o que me fez gostar
de ciência
quando eu era pequena meu pai me deu uma
enciclopédia que a ciência ilustrada na
capa dela tinha o globo a terra então
queria conhecer e explorar e dentro dela
cada página que eu lia eu vi equações eu
via as fórmulas uma série de coisas
circuitos e eu queria ler mais descobrir
mais e perguntava e perguntava era muito
curiosa e meu pai me responde é sempre
que eu perguntava então a curiosidade
minha eles sempre e eu fui gostando foi
tomando gosto que talvez querendo mais e
mais e mais
então aí que está a resposta para que a
gente traga mais meninas paciência a
gente precisa mostrar para essas meninas
onde é que estão as outras cientistas
existisse mulher fazendo ciência existe
mulher negra fazendo ciência
esse número 7 por cento corresponde a 5
mil pesquisadoras e elas estão aí
distribuídas pelas universidades
então se a gente puder contar para as
meninas a história dessas pesquisadoras
elas vão ter modelos para que elas
possam se inspirar amanhã e é atrás
disso que eu fui e comecei a fazer
divulgação dessas histórias
eu comecei a contar nas palestras
visitas às escolas e mostrar essa
problemática até que o aluno me disse
professor os problemas nós já conhecemos
então o que nós precisamos de ações para
poder mudar de idéia
então fui atrás de ações e serviços que
eu falei uma coisa interessante aquelas
fotos
as mulheres estão muito longe uma das
outras duas estão muito separadas
então que a gente precisa a gente
precisa dar as mãos a gente precisa
estar unidos
se eu a mão pra você você dá um para a
outra pra outra é muito mais fácil a
gente chega na porta
então nós vamos somar conhecimento então
nós temos que estar unidas pra que a
gente possa inspirar e ter a ciência
então é isso que a gente precisa fazer
então todas juntas e uma coisa
importante é como fica o papel dos
homens nessa situação é importante que
os homens entendam que se eles estiverem
sozinhos eles até podem mais depressa
mas se eles estiverem de mãos dadas com
as mulheres tiveram juntos nós há muito
mais longe mas muito mais longe porque
quero trabalhar com a diversidade e
quando se trabalha com a diversidade na
pesquisa você vai muito mais longe se
alcança muito mais caminhos e alcança
muito mais pessoas e pra gente atingir
isso para que a gente consiga fazer isso
nós precisamos aqui nós precisamos
inspirar nossas meninas nós precisamos
respirar nossas crianças e isso eu vou
buscar onde na minha história de vida eu
tiver alguém que me inspirou porque o
que faz a diferença entre ter um certo
número de mulheres fazendo ciência ou
outra não são as oportunidades e se você
não tiver oportunidade
então você tem que criar las durante
todo esse tempo em que eu estudei muitas
das vezes e houve oportunidade no
exterior eu queria estar cursando fora o
que eu fiz eu mandei marcar
eu entrei em contato com as outras
universidades e conseguir auxílio para
poder estar fora do brasil e isso ajudou
muito a minha carreira isso fortaleceu
inclusive tem um trabalho que a gente
tem que é um trabalho famoso o pessoal
brinca a colaboração pessoal da nasa
professor lado os estados unidos então
esse é um trabalho que mudou
revolucionou a minha carreira mas isso
porque porque eu fui atrás de uma
oportunidade e ela é itu era passar por
minhas meninas é essa inspiração que eu
quero está passando para as meninas
então nós precisamos em poderá inspirar
essas meninas e como essas ações são
feitas essas ações são feitas colocando
a mão na massa
então nós precisamos é a onde essas
crianças estão e incentivar essas
crianças a praticar a fazer ciência
então nós vamos uma escola e as crianças
vão aprender a programar
estamos nos sentindo poderá dados porque
elas vão programar com uma garota elas
vão fazer coisas que são importante e
que vão fazer diferença na vida delas
amanhã elas vão montar um circuito então
eu nem senti que elas estão entendendo o
que elas estão fazendo ea gente vai
ampliando as brincadeiras consciência e
ao mesmo tempo empoderando elas para que
elas se sintam donas de si para que elas
se sintam confiantes no que estão
fazendo
e quem é que vai até as escolas comigo
nesse trabalho são os alunos da
universidade
então essas alunas esses alunos que vão
comigo quando eles fazem esse trabalho
além de incentivar a inspirar outras
crianças ele também sente os piratas
porque ele sente como agente
multiplicador então jovem tem muito
disso esse empreendedorismo científico e
social
então isso ajuda bastante nesses dois
anos de projeto
nós já visitamos várias escolas nós já
atendemos várias meninas e o programa só
tende a crescer porque porque tem magia
da vez mais pessoas estão fazendo uma
rede onde as pessoas estão conectadas
pra dar continuidade
trabalho então eu coloquei a mãozinha aí
para representar duas coisas as mãos
dadas que a gente precisa da prata unida
umas com as outras uns com os outros e
pôr a mão na massa que a gente tem que
fazer então as crianças gostam muito do
fazer eu quero sim que as meninas sejam
cientistas que bom que elas sejam
cientistas que elas gostam de matemática
da engenharia da física da química
mas além disso eu quero que elas sejam
que donas da sua vontade
donas de si próprias então elas podem
ser cientista sim mas elas também podem
ser o que elas quiserem e elas podem
estar onde elas quiserem porque é isso
que a gente quer
são essas ações que a gente quer para o
mundo é isso que estamos fazendo em
poder as nossas meninas para que elas
sejam que ela se quiser como elas
quiserem
obrigada
[Aplausos]
[Música]